los Anillos Olímpicos ocupan un lugar de
honor frente a la alcaldía de París pero
la ciudad no está preparada para los
juegos el entusiasmo del público es
escaso debido a que las primeras
entradas a la venta se consideraban
demasiado caras sí son los precios 50
100 euros es un poco caro es una pena no
creo que esté muy bien organizado al
menos la comunicación el responsable de
comunicaciones de los juegos es Tony
reconoce que los precios de las entradas
son elevados a veces varios cientos de
euros para tres eventos a pesar de las
promesas iniciales de unos juegos
asequibles la venta de entradas
representa un tercio de nuestro
presupuesto para nosotros es muy
importante maximizar los ingresos en
taquilla a 500 días del comienzo de uno
de los mayores acontecimientos
deportivos del planeta París se renueva
en el barrio de la chapela al norte de
la ciudad las excavadoras y las grúas ya
forman parte del paisaje nuevos
edificios y nuevas infraestructuras de
transporte algunos están encantados las
líneas de metro que se han construido o
renovado es también para las personas de
movilidad reducida pero necesitamos más
no solo para las olimpiadas es una
transformación rápida que avanza con
paso firme para estar lista el día de la
inauguración como este bloque de pisos
que se utilizará como hotel Durante los
juegos un poco más lejos se encuentra la
futura Villa Olímpica que acogerá
atletas de todo el mundo estarán entre
ellos sus atletas rusos en los últimos
meses han aumentado los llamados incluso
por parte de la alcaldesa a Hidalgo para
que se excluya de los juegos a los
atletas de Rusia y velarus pero la
decisión final corresponde al comité
olímpico internacional